Speaker 1: Why don't we speak next to.
Oh, I don't know. Why don't we go to our friend
Bitdefender from Cancun? Bitdefender. Welcome.
Hello. Hello.
Speaker 3: It was fun. Yes,
I did. I was listening to an episode of yours
earlier this week with Mr. Coleman, who's.
And you you mentioned this idea in
which people have to play dirty to move
forward. You know how you sort of say
circumstances we have to bend or break the rules?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I guess I have to
be clear. What I what I said was
there are people who argue that to achieve real
change, you have to play dirty and break rules.
I wasn't necessarily asserting it myself on
any particular issue, but I was proposing
it as a thought element for the conversation.
Speaker 3: Yes, there is exactly that. And I know
you don't necessarily espouse that idea. Okay.
And I wanted to expound a little bit on on why you
wouldn't want to close that, because I don't think
you mentioned it in depth in that segment. But
ultimately, all boils down to it is precisely
this attitude which allows, you know, while well,
we may say, well, we're doing some menial evil for
a greater good, the same logic gets perverted to,
you know, defend a greater good for
myself in exchange for a greater herd
from the rest of the world, I guess, you know.
Speaker 1: Let me see if I understand what you're
saying. Let me see if I can summarize what you're
saying. You're saying the problem with justifying
breaking rules or laws in order to achieve a
particular outcome. If you evaluate that the
outcome is worthwhile, is that once you open that
door, next thing you know, you're saying, well,
maybe murder is okay to justify a good outcome or
maybe raping and pillaging of an entire village or
whatever. You're saying that it's a slippery slope
of sorts once we say, well, you can decide whether
these are laws that should be broken to achieve
a goal. You've kind of entered an area that lends
itself to all sorts of different justifications.
Speaker 3: Yes, that's exactly right. And the
problem is precisely that more than the slippery
slope argument is more of, well, they are willing
to play the long game and take tiny steps to
achieve those goals. While we are usually,
you know, we have a mind of we need to make big
changes for the world to be a better place. Hmm.
Speaker 1: That's an interesting idea. Yeah.
I mean, the problem is that there really are
sometimes laws that are unjust. And I'm not
talking about murder. Right. But there are
sometimes laws that are unjust when it comes to
protesting or being heard in different ways that
that sort of that type of thing. So I think that
that that's the difficulty of it. Bitdefender,
I have to ask, where are you calling from? Because
not only are you echoey, there was like a speaker
phone announcement a couple of minutes ago.
Speaker 3: I am so sorry. It's just part of
the job in a police station, you know?
Speaker 1: Oh, you're in station.
Speaker 3: Wow. Wow. Yeah. I'm sorry.
Speaker 1: I'm sure I'll have to visit next time.
Next time I'm in Cancun, I'll have to visit
the police station and see what you're up to.
Speaker 3: The tourism police
station, particularly? Yes, tourism.
You're free to come any time.
Speaker 1: Beautiful. All right,
Bitdefender. Thank you for the call.
Speaker 3: Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right. There's Bitdefender
from Mexico. Always great to hear from him